shannon bream is tracking our fox news
voter analysis survey with the latest
numbers shannon what's on the minds of
virginia voters well good evening martha
and brett still too soon right to know
our winner but the candidates both have
a very solid base of supporters so let's
dig into what the numbers are telling us
with mcauliffe's experience and
political connections and the state's
recent voting trends this race was his
to lose youngkin the political newcomer
with his business savvy has really
surprised many by making this a very
tight contest here's what we know so far
from our fox news voter analysis
election survey let's take a look at the
strengths for each candidate a majority
of voters under 45 years old support
mcauliffe he's got a 15 point edge there
there's even stronger support for
mcauliffe among women under the age of
45 giving him a 26 point lead the middle
ground moderates give mcauliffe a
similar lead about 25 points there black
voters almost always go solidly for the
democrat and a large majority here does
support mcauliffe giving him a huge 75
point advantage
important to note that while mcauliffe
has advantages among these groups he is
running behind the support levels that
these same groups had for the democrat
in the last governor's race now that is
how young kin is making this a closer
race than a lot of people ever expected
so let's take a look at young kids
strengths seniors ages 65 and older were
more likely than any other group to vote
early as in prior to election day not
early this morning more than half report
voting in advance now young can hold a
14 point advantage with that group this
is big increase in support from seniors
since the 2017 gubernatorial contest
there in virginia another strong group
for yunkan is white men he's getting six
in ten of them about a third of the
electorate are white voters without a
college degree and young penn has a
strong 35 point lead among the working
class voters finally even stronger is
young can support from white evangelical
christians it's a small but cohesive
group 8 and 10 say they're with him
there is a battle going on for fully one
half of voters who live in the suburbs
the hard fought group that group gives a
very slight edge to mcauliffe exciting
stuff we're getting more numbers all the
time we've got much more fox news voter
analysis of the virginia gubernatorial
race in the coming hours spread martha
back to you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else